but we're going to begin with the
breaking news I know you've heard
President Biden just announced
officially that he is running for
reelection and it came in the form of
this video message
every generation Americans
to have to defend Democracy stand up for
our personal freedom stand up for the
right to vote in our civil rights
[Music]
and this is our moment
the president already has support from
many prominent Democrats but he does
face some very tough headwinds our new
CBS News poll shows his approval rating
is just 41 percent that's close to where
it's been for more than a year now we
Zhang is at the White House good morning
I know it's a very big day there but a
lot of people don't feel he should run
in this country good morning to you good
morning to you Gail good morning to
everybody the president would say that
that is nothing new and he has dealt
with that before he has said watch me
now the timing for today is no accident
it marks exactly four years since then
candidate Joe Biden announced he was
entering the race for president now
President Biden has a record to run on
but that means he also has to answer for
campaign promises that are so far
unfulfilled
this is not a time to be complacent
[Music]
that's why I'm running for re-election
in a pre-taped video message Tuesday
President Biden officially launched his
2024 presidential re-election campaign
when I ran for president four years ago
I said we're in a battle for the soul of
America and we still are
the question we're facing is whether in
the years ahead we have more freedom or
less Freedom more rights are fewer I
know what I want there
[Music]
President Biden remains focused on the
big issues likely to shape the 2024 race
for the White House issues like gun
violence which he addressed during a
meeting Monday with three Tennessee
Democratic lawmakers two of whom were
kicked out of office for a time for
protesting on the floor of their state
house he also slammed Republicans for
meddling in schools I never thought I'd
be a president who was fighting against
elected officials trying to ban and
banning books
empty shelves don't help kids learn very
much
and continues the Battle Cry for the
protection of a woman's Reproductive
Rights ahead of the re-election
announcement as CBS News poll found
Democrats accept Biden's re-election bid
but aren't necessarily excited about it
and still nearly half of Democrats don't
want the 80 year old to run and they
cite his age as the reason you're
thinking about running for the
presidency it's less about the polling
and it's more about is the environment
Rich for me CBS News political
contributor Ashley Etienne says the
timing also has to do with drawing a
contrast with the current GOP
front-runner former president Donald
Trump the environment is really rich for
this announcement with Donald Trump's
back against the wall with the
indictment out of New York and facing
prosecution from Georgia all the way to
New York State even with Trump gaining a
big endorsement Monday from Montana
Senator Steve daines who chairs the
Senate Republicans campaign arm Biden's
announcement show confidence that he
thinks he can win in 2024. let's finish
this job I know we can
following this morning's video
announcement President Biden will focus
on will likely what will likely be a big
campaign pitch and that's focusing on
American jobs later today he's set to
deliver remarks here in Washington about
bringing manufacturing back and
rebuilding the middle class Tony
all right he always says watch me I know
you will be Ouija thank you very much